[Music]
how are you
everybody merry christmas seasons
greetings uh happy holidays
uh and all that good stuff uh from me hi
i'm kevin smith how are you uh okay
i uh this is my 50th christmas kids
50th christmas on this best of all
possible earths
and um this year of course we were all
spread out me and my family is the first
christmas
that i've spent without my daughter
since she's been born
her and her boyfriend are in dallas
working on a free-form tv show
uh so it's just me and my wife jen here
her parents who lived with us they were
at their place in nevada
and so we were all separated and whatnot
and uh it's a weird
christmas for us but rather than let it
be weird and focus on
you know the mopey nature of like oh man
i'm not doing what we normally do every
year and stuff like that
uh i'm gonna flip the script and share a
christmas gift with you folks
uh if you're into my [ __ ] otherwise you
might be like i'm gonna give a [ __ ]
about this
but this is my christmas wish for you
may you uh get to be you in this life
and do exactly what you want to
do unless what you want to do is like
kill people hunt humans don't do that
then i hope you never get that
but if you have simple basic wishes like
i want to be a storyteller
like [ __ ] that dude he's been doing
it for over 25 years and he's not very
good at it
why can't i be like a kevin smith you
can
kids it's absolutely possible um but
this
is what uh my christmas wish to you is
you get to be everything you want to be
but my christmas advice to you is to
take notes
keep a journal um because you never know
like when it'll come in handy or when
it'll pop back into your life
quick story years ago uh me and my
friend vincent pereira
uh went to see bad lieutenant at the
angelica film center
um in uh in manhattan and uh
that was where i first saw slacker made
me want to be a filmmaker on my 21st
birthday august 2nd
1991 that's important that's the moment
that i'm like i want to be a director i
want to be a filmmaker
vinnie was the first person i ever knew
wanted to be a filmmaker
like he had the dream before i did he
knew that people could do that sort of
thing i thought
he had to come from hollywood to do that
sort of thing
so um vinnie uh plays big role
in clerks ever getting made because i
meet vinnie he's the
mop boy at uh quick stop knights comes
in from nine to ten thirty mops of floor
and ship
so um vinnie's the one that's like all
about film knows about aspect ratios and
he wants to grow up to be a director and
i was like you gotta be from hollywood
for that sort of thing he's like no
so in my mind me and vinnie go see
bad lieutenant at the angelica vinnie's
car gets robbed his trunk gets broken
into and that's where i had
this canvas warner brothers script bag
that i had
um where i stored you know my papers it
was like my man bag or my book bag or
something have my
bills and my checkbook um you know there
was no
cell phones i didn't have that there was
no laptops i didn't have that
so notebooks papers you know comic books
i'd carry a lot of comic books to read
in any given moment notice
that bag got stolen from vinnie's trunk
when we went to see bad lieutenant and
whatnot and
in that bag was a notebook in which i
started
what would become clerks um in a book
that i was calling
inconvenience and in my memory that book
was stolen
with the rest of the stuff in the bag
and i never saw it again
and then just this week ladies and
gentlemen
i found it i was digging through some
[ __ ] and i
found the damn book this is a
composition
notebook look at that this is my real
cursive writing kevin smith
old ph grade 8 it was for classwork
but what it became about is this
inconvenience a story of
goods and bads
pun the journal and it says being a
young screenwriter's notebook
journalizing the construction of his
first
serious effort at filmic writing what
an overworty douchebag young kevin smith
was
this is the book kids this is the book
in my mind like i was like well
you know that book's gone that was the
book that when i was on a train
to pittsburgh uh to go visit my
girlfriend back then
i you know i wrote some dialogue it's
gone forever
it's not gone forever it's literally
here and there's an entry
listen to this where i say like
i'm on a train where i literally
say um where is it
where is it uh october 29th 1991
i'm on a train so guess where this scene
comes from
connie and darren behind the counter
there was no dante and randall they were
called
connie and darren in inconvenience and
then
the scene that i wrote is a scene from a
different movie altogether it was from
chasing amy
where they're sitting there and watching
people make out in the car um it was a
cut scene from chasing amy
so holy [ __ ] what a mind better but more
importantly
august 2nd 1991 i go see slacker that's
the day where i'm like i'm going to be a
filmmaker and stuff
so that's how i remember everything
this journal was started on july 1st
1991
like a full month and a day before i see
slacker so
when i start this journal i'm not
thinking about being a filmmaker i'm
thinking about writing a
script about working in a convenience
store then
a month later i see slacker and i was
like you know what i think i could
direct it too
so i'm just going to share with you the
opening passage
of this year notebook to show you what a
young
kev smith was thinking about and
hopefully this will inspire you to be
like i sound like that dude
like oh my god why can't i do it and
then you'll
figure out the you know oh my god i can
do it i don't need permission
i don't need help i can pull [ __ ]
together myself because kevin smith's a
[ __ ]
chimp and he figured this out 26 years
ago so i bet you i can figure this out
right now
so this will help you build your
confidence because this
is what uh the guy who wanted to make a
movie not called clerks
but called inconvenience uh vinnie
thank the lord stop me from calling it
inconvenience vinnie was the first one
to be like
title's a little precious he's like it's
a little on the nose you know don't you
think
very punny inconvenience and i was like
all right well
i guess i'll call it something else and
one day we're working at the stores on a
quick stop minnie was at rst video
he broke down a bunch of potential names
for what you know the movie could be
called and one of the names of the the
six
or eight funny names they were all very
sarcastic and stuff
one of the names was rude clerks and
that made me laugh so hard cause i'm
like oh my god
that literally describes the whole
[ __ ] movie like they're root clerks
and it was a joke but then i was like
but you know
you dropped the rude and clerks is a
pretty [ __ ] cool title it really just
[ __ ] explains everything doesn't it
so
back before it was clerksman was just
inconvenience
this is the first entry in this book uh
july 1st 1991
so this july this will be 30 years old
so almost 30 years ago uh 29 and a half
years ago
this is what i was thinking
this was me plotting the rest of my life
let's see how close
i get ready july 1 1991 after about
two days worth of hearty procrastination
in regards to this endeavor
on this very day before the sneak
preview of terminator 2
that places us in time in history i
finally take the time to begin what i'm
curious to see what might metamorphosize
into a
filmable screenplay inconvenience
listen to this douchebag oh my god he
loves the sound of his own voice even
though he ain't talking he loves
words he's a little wordsmith he
believes and i still believe it to this
day the young kevin smith believes it
and old kevin smith believes it
there's no such thing as sorcery or
wizardry
um sorry with all apologies to jk
rowling
no apologies to jk rowling uh there's no
we know there's no such thing as
magic spells and magic words but when
you write
there is a form of magic words man
because you put words together
and then like an incantation you give it
to somebody they read it or they hear it
and it changes their mood it changes how
they feel
they can laugh cry be moved taken on a
journey
learn something and whatnot if those
that ain't the very definition of magic
words i don't know what it is so there
are wizards and warlocks and [ __ ]
sorcerers and sorceresses out there kids
they're called writers uh they're called
creators very people on this platform
facebook or on
youtube people who are like i'm going to
make a thing anybody who makes a [ __ ]
thing
is about is a [ __ ] creator man and
you're all wizards
and and witches and warlocks and
sorcerers and sorcerers
because you got that magic words you
could create your own universes
all right let me give you the rundown
he's so courteous this young kev smith
he's going to let us know where we are
in the story and the story is just
beginning
this is the day before we go see the
sneak preview for terminator 2 for
[ __ ] sake
let me give you the rundown about three
months ago the title came to me in
wonder of wonders
work since then it's been applied to a
surreal story about late night
convenience store work
featuring a cast of bizarre and
moderately neato characters i stole that
moderately needle from george carlin
a potential sitcom when i considered
taking a one-day seminar
in new york city i don't remember that
me dreaming about making a sitcom
a film short that makes sense and
eventually an abandoned brainstorm
thrown atop a pile of countless
abandoned brainstorms that had been
birthed in a flash of brilliance
and relinquished with little
afterthought
this [ __ ] guy boy does he love words
and then vinnie sends a prayer vinnie my
muse said
something we were at work not working
and he was having me relate the tragic
tale of brian that's brian johnson from
tell him steve did brian's love affair
du jour
with laura the narrative soap operatic
though it may be
had my companion riveted then he was
riveted
the story was apparently compelling and
in the middle of it
vincent says and i quote you should make
this
into a screenplay set here in the store
like metropolitan we were big fans of
the whit stillman's movie metropolitan
vinnie vinnie pereira not only like
taught me about film but vinnie
apparently is the guy that was like you
should make a movie in the store
i i mean i know vinnie was deep in my
origins and stuff but like thank god i
found this
i could pinpoint like [ __ ] moment in
time where all of a sudden i was like
yeah she'd write a script based in the
convenience store
um this i thought this story about
strange friendships set in a convenience
store
inconvenience bingo
and it was born and i saw what it was
and it was good
so we definitely have a setting and
after much thought
i came up with the story uh which there
is
of which there is little a day at the
stop
for this a huge nod goes to spike the
king lee
i'm a big spike lee fan and his
masterpiece do the right thing one of my
favorite movies ever made
um i have a feeling a lot of nods are
going to go to this man in his films
because
as flavor flav says look at me name
dropping flavor flav
spike's the one you like uh
the man makes incredible films that are
from frame one to fade out
uniquely his own and this has served as
inspiration for myself
and my film so i saw him do the right
thing
and for some reason i was like i could
be a filmmaker i've never made do the
right thing i'd say anything nearly as
good as do the right thing
but i have made movies set in the span
of one day
and that's about as close as i get but
enough ass
kissing about my movie
let's talk about my movie we have a
where quick stop
a convenience store a when and a what
the average day
now we need a slew of who's and i think
i've got a couple our main character is
me
not me kevin but me the beleaguered
misanthropic
youth who runs a small indian owned and
operated convenience store
i thought of myself as misanthropic in
in july of 91. i go figure
um let's see he's cantankerous
he's sarcastic he sounds more like
randall
he's 21 or so his life is spent there
and in the video store
which his bosses also own so he's
developed an
underlying enmity for every person that
comes through the door
that kind of describes clerks uh
he's smug and ultra condescending god
forbid you say something halfway not in
the know for example
somebody in the video store asking for
batman 2
which sends our hero into convulsive
shutters of disgust
do you have an inside line to warner
brothers that the rest of the world
doesn't know about
oh my god how droll he's a lover of
literature films
cartoons he wears bugs bunny shirts and
comic books
describes my whole [ __ ] life the rest
of my life after
after i i made clerks as well hopefully
[ __ ]
um a plot device that could be
interesting
should one of his comic books get
damaged i saved that from all that
comics there are only a few people he
does willingly converse with
but the rest he looks down on uh the
burden as the burden of his being in
short he can't be
bothered by life he's too wrapped up
in his microcosm that does kind of sound
like [ __ ] dante and clerks
onto bry's character so i knew i was
basing a character on brian johnson
he's the flip side of my own bra has a
cheery disposition blithe
now that's ridiculous because
in real life bry was the bry was the
negative misanthrope and i was the
cheery
disposition guy but in writing a
character based on me i wanted to be the
anti-hero
rather than the straight arrow [ __ ]
lead guy um
and we know how that turned out
uh he always has a kind word
for the customers yeah that sounds like
brian johnson he's the fav rave at the
quick stop
no see i flipped all this this became
dante the perennial good guy as opposed
to
my forever sour anti-hero bry should be
a composite like in new york magazine
that's a
direct steal from the movie metropolitan
uh shout out to whit stoneman
should be a composite of brian himself a
bit of bellicose my friend mike
bellicose
and my nicer side he's in love with this
girl
um that i had my character had gone with
and this may or may not be causing
tensions
kev's character and bry's character are
good friends and people have to wonder
why
since they're so diametrically opposed
that very much sounds like dante randall
but
i didn't do the whole like there's a
girl between them think thank god that's
so trite
um but that was the only thing going on
in my life at that time so i was like
you know vinnie said that make a good
movie i was like all right [ __ ] let's
do that
see listen to your friends kids unless
they're like let's do crimes then don't
listen to your friends
unless they're like they're victimless
crimes and then you know uh
let's see um
through dialogue we learned that brian
kev were once very much alike but the
introduction of love has metamorphosized
brian
into a congenial soul ah so there it was
my randall character was getting sweep
because he was in love
kev uh finds difficulty in comprehending
bry's change of heart
but brian understands that kev's
misogyny
doesn't sound like misogyny to me
apparently i didn't know what that word
meant is only superficial there you go
he loves a woman but there are
complications between them
so he curses the whole because of the
one
instead of getting emotionally involved
sounds like one of them uh
insults apparently [ __ ] my character
was an insult before the insult movement
began
uh let's see he loves a woman i did that
instead of getting emotionally involved
kev
just get the kev character just gets
laid
that's [ __ ] movie wishful thinking
right there
uh and i might want to include that as
well a good down and dirty back room
sex scene convenience store work isn't
all milk and eggs you know
he literally wrote that nearly 21
and a month from now he'll be 21 years
old so 20 year old kev
just wrote that line i smell a fight
scene toward the end
that [ __ ] stayed that idea made it
all the way through to the end
between the two friends as kev says uh
just one thing too much and bry loses it
and that became the reverse
randalls did one thing too much and
dante lost it
i see chips tumbling and pretzels
getting crushed
while the dvd no while the duo because
dvd didn't exist yet
the duo have their all-out free-for-all
brouhaha
and the customers looked on shocked
next up is the vin man's character this
one will probably be the hardest to get
on the page
due to the fact that vinnie himself is
almost too erratic
and volatile to get a lead on good lord
he should have more in common with the
kev character
the guy almost never works although his
duties are meager at best
he's too preoccupied with conversation
to do his work and he spends almost
all of his time reading the various
magazines so there was going to be a
third
character in clerks um vinnie's
character but then eventually it just
in the script when this is
inconvenienced when it became clerk's
just dante and ramble
um he's too he is highly intellectual
but not very worldly uh that describes
all my characters and me
and is somewhat cynical and misanthropic
but not nearly as much
as the kev character he is a foil for
much of kev's observation
sounds like a elias relationship
it sounds like a randall elias
relationship which would come years
later in clerks 2.
um typical banter
kev says and it's my lock to allow my
genius to stagnate
is it my lot no he goes and it's my law
to allow my genius to stagnate as i wait
on the drugs of society
and then he says there's always dominoes
um
thank god that didn't dialogue didn't
wind up in clerks because not very good
the customers will be many and varied
but i don't want to go into them now
i'm done in fact for now i'll say this
i do know how the film will end
and it ain't pretty i'm not [ __ ]
nuts that's that's
the very seeds of
the rocket ship that would change the
rest of my life
i was building a rocket ship i was
trying to get to another planet
planet where you know they made movies
and indie film exists and stuff like
that
that's how the journey began uh it goes
on
would you like to hear some sample
dialogue between connie and kurt here
i'll read you one more page here we go
minutes before july 2nd
1991 i was on a roll i wrote the next
night as well shakespearean quotes
i want to include them in the dialogue
it will just add a classy touch
and sound like a new jersey mobster
that's classy uh
and the movie game we played out a great
deal and i'm sure
many do the world over mind you this is
before the internet
1991 so i didn't know what the rest of
the world did and the movie game is like
uh you say we need a bigger boat and
somebody goes jaws
that's simple but we didn't wind up
doing that movie but they talked
in movie dialogue and my character who
now
is called conrad connie for short so
dante was meant to be connie
has a very anti-collegiate edge just
like the author
in fact it's not anti-collegiate so much
as anti-college
fever his ex goes to a college and is
buried knee-deep
in extracurricular activities and connie
hates that [ __ ]
so here's some sample dialogue connie
goes she's a [ __ ] spirit bunny
and kurt who apparently is randall says
she's someone else's spirit bunny
um and then and that's thank god i
didn't use that [ __ ] lime dial
and it says in every 20 minutes new
coffee
is being brewed um
wow wow kids number one
i thought this was lost to the ages and
gone in a garbage can
in the streets of manhattan after
vinnie's car got broken into but
here it is and apparently i was thinking
about writing a convenience store
screenplay before i was thinking about
directing it before i thought about like
oh i could do this myself i was just
like i'm going to write this screenplay
and then hopefully somebody will one day
make it well kids
don't wait for us hopefully don't wait
for some day
don't wait for anybody no help's ever
coming i hate to break this to you on
christmas but
you want to count on somebody make your
dreams come true
count on yourself count on a good
handful of friends who
you know will be there for you thick and
thin
and together even though you're a bunch
of rubes and idiots
you could build something that changes
your life that's what we did we didn't
know what we were doing we were absolute
beginners man we were amateurs and stuff
but you heard exactly what that amateur
sounded like
and what his dreams were and how close
he [ __ ] got please as we leave this
horrible
[ __ ] 2020 and head to 2021
remember this because this is the year
where you
make your clerks whatever that is
whether it's a movie or [ __ ] knitting
a blanket or [ __ ] dropping a bunch of
weight
it begins in 2021 kids and i don't mean
dropping well dropping weight if that's
your thing
getting healthier um this
it's all possible and start writing
[ __ ] down maybe not long hand use your
laptops and [ __ ]
but keep notes from this time this time
that predicates change you'll want to
revisit it
i promise you um and also uh
this has nothing to do with me or my
work but my advice to you here on uh
christmas day
is try to always live your life
like your bill murray in the last 10
minutes of scrooged
you know don't be the shitheal he was
the whole movie
be the guy or the girl who comes around
and goes i get it now
i get it um that's how i try to live my
life
every damn day like i'm bill murray in
the last 10 minutes of scrooged
um thank you all for hanging out and
listening
to this sentimental journey the seeds of
what became clerks
i'll keep reading it over at that kevin
smith club
um if you're if you're if you've not
seen it come join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com
um but failing that thank you all
for the support all year long thanks to
everyone who came to movies thanks to
everyone who
wrote about man i wish movies was coming
to me in 2021 it may be coming your way
um and thanks for continued interest in
my [ __ ] man
this kid he dreamed of this
he dreamed of you that he would make
stuff that would connect with people who
would then
follow his work and be like oh i love
kevin i'm a kevin smith person the same
way i was like a spike lee person
or a hal heartley person like and that
wish came true so
thank you all of you for making that
wish come true man you
you were who i was thinking about when i
was writing these notes
that potential audience so merry
christmas everybody seasons greetings
holiday
happy holidays and stuff happy hanukkah
mary kwanzaa uh all of those
happy festivus to the rest of us and
stuff
um and uh in 2021 let's just
try to be a little kinder to everybody
it was a little rough [ __ ] year last
year i mean
think about how rough your year was
everybody had a year that was as bad if
not worse so
as we head into 2021 in like a week's
time
let's try to give each other the benefit
of doubt try to be kinder
try to make some stuff try to make our
mark in 2021 and not in a negative way
in a good way go be creative don't be
destructive two paths in this world
destruction creation destruction path is
crowded kids because
it's easy to break things down destroy
mock blah blah creation path
wide open all lanes are open you cruise
because it takes a little bit more takes
it takes commitment takes giving
something of yourself
uh to be creative and a lot of people
you know just aren't willing to do that
but the good news for you is that means
it's not crowded that means you get on
that freeway of creativity
man you drive for the rest of your life
you just keep making stuff making stuff
making stuff until one day you drop dead
can't think of a better way to live this
best of all possible lives merry
christmas everybody
from the guy who a lot of people are
like why what the [ __ ] ever happened to
silent bob i liked him better when he
was quiet
uh from chatty kev merry christmas
everybody
um happy holidays and uh
it's maybe awkward for some of you but
uh you know
i'm gonna end it awkward i love you all
merry christmas
you